[Music]
get
Sean move around so you can get whatever
you need to get so you guys learn
[Music]
this
there three details I'd like to get is
this part over here try to stand up you
see you you have it adhesion on this arm
okay so you don't need to Fumble here
but you can't let go of that adhesion
okay it's on the inside of his arm so
let's say uh he tries to go forward I
take it into the circle you see so for
example he's trying to go
forward to take it right back into the
circle there's a forward pressure on it
okay now here he tries to get up that's
what I want that's what takes him into
the technique okay I'm going to come
[Music]
around second part I'd like you to get
is this elbow like all the other
kadat has to go on the front side can't
go on the back side that's not going to
work he going to be strong you're not
going to get it has to go on the front
side so you have to work that in through
your
pins oh this has to go on the front side
there it is right
there can't be too
moves front side there it is on the
front
front side on the
front get that ha on the front side on
the pin
go so if I'm
doing if I'm doing n i I don't want to
be in the joint I don't want to cut the
joint I'm using the joint lock to be in
his Center in his Center in Hiser okay
so s is no
different when I come around here I
don't want to turn I'm not trying to
turn this and stay in the joint I'm
using the joint lock to put it in his
body this
way so don't turn
here hold there and that goes in his
body so I have to find a way of taking
energy from here up his arm and into his
Center hits his body that's what makes
him move it's still in his body it's
still there you see still there so I'm
going to go around that energy and
that's when it so push on me you see
it's there I'm going to get out of the
way of this and cut it
down the more you twist his wrists the
stronger you have to be so if all your
thing is about hurting him he's stronger
than me here don't hurt my thumb cuz
it's jacked up just do it slowly
untwist so I'm going to have to do it
here now do you see and he's still
stronger than me do it slow don't hurt
me there you go you see but instead I'm
in his
body you see that difference I'm not in
the wrist fix
yourself you all right
yeah so this goes in his body in his
body then
around in his body this
way
get out of the
wrist cannot smell the pin and go to the
pin okay so when you're here like this
it's not going to be shove him down push
down you're going to use an inverse
spiral of EO to get him down so that's
why I need him to go that
way then I'm going to cut down don't
smell this pin it's not there I'm going
to bre take this elbow controled now and
keep him turning around then he'll fall
okay
so what I'm seeing is you have one more
ten con to do
boom
H into him
one two one more ten con I'm going to
bring him this way
into him one two not enough don't smell
that one around
again
that's what helps his elbow get on the
front side of
me I'll show two hand transition details
in the version we're doing okay so we'll
we have first
part this part here okay
so this comes here this will take over
there there you have your elbow control
I'm going to go inside and go to that
adhesion
control then I'll have a fulcrum here in
between this
fulcrum and this elbow control I can
turn my hands turn my hand and grab his
finger fingers that's the first thing
there's not don't grab sonio yet I
cannot get Sono there don't grab Sono
here
transition to
there there is your Sono when he comes
up and I let him up okay so
again here in
place turn don't come off turn
around take his pinky push it behind
that'll have your smaller hands will
work just fine here those finger locks
are helping the energy go into him so
don't have it here you need to put those
finger locks in the place where the
energy can go into him to grip the
sunu there it is right there so again
you got
here boom there's adhesion on the arm
boom adhesion roll around in
place don't lose
contact again we're here stand up nope
stand up nope stand up nope stand up
nope okay doesn't mean he can stand up
because I keep those adhesions in place
next one we
finished okay and we're going to come
around here is a pin okay that elbow
goes in place and you can see how
mechanically awkward that is so open up
this
finger put your chest on his hand and
this hand comes up and puts his hand on
your chest so you're here you can see
how I would be here right it's going to
get very awkward that's very awkward so
before it gets awkward I change hands
I'm in the same block same
lock this controls the elbow to give me
the bend to give me the leverage I need
so he has a straight arm he'll come Bend
his elbow you'll get it can do it this
way you can do it with the technique
Keon but you can't have a straight arm
he'll be too strong Bend in place so
again you're going to get
here just open up the finger don't keep
going like that that looks so awkward it
is awkward here open the finger and
replace here open the finger come
underneath you grab the
SLE you can see it's still SEL still
Sonu still Sonu in place okay get those
two hand transitions clean them up